hello brooklyn heights
hi dallas how are you i'm good first and
foremost
congrats on canada's drag race this show
was massive and it wasn't just massive
here in canada
it was massive worldwide were you
surprised by the amount
of people all around the world who fell
in love with this series
yesterday no i mean being there i knew
people were going to
love the show and just seeing how
amazing things were and how
authentically themselves they were the
whole time like they really didn't hold
anything back and they were just
there was no uh self-editing and stuff
like that that you sometimes see they
were just
they just said it how they felt it and
kind of were just themselves so i knew
it was gonna be really really good tv
and i'm just so happy that
people connected with it and enjoyed it
it was amazing i wasn't sure how like
competitive they were gonna be but
everyone just really
came to win and i think what impressed
me most um
was like the challenges we gave them and
how they would just kind of go for them
for you as a judge real talk here the
fandom was
um i feel like a little tough on you
as judges for some reason i think people
assume that because it was a canadian
version
it was gonna be all sunshine rainbows
kisses and that's not
a reality television show had you done
like a high-waisted baggy pant and then
like cinched in corset over top of that
lost the chunky boot and done a
sickening stiletto with like a purse
with all that with like a gold chain
belt so completely different
completely different season one was
absolutely a huge learning experience i
think people forget that i had never
been in this position i was in before
last time i was on drag race i was a
contestant and all of a sudden i'm
the first queen ever to be made a judge
so
automatically i knew i was gonna have a
target on my back because
whenever whenever you're put in a
position of authority over other people
automatically people are going to be
like well what does she know like she
didn't even win blah blah blah all of
this stuff
and that comes with the territory it
kind of taught me to have a thicker skin
because when i was on drug race i kind
of escaped
um a lot of negativity from the fandom
and it got really hard for a couple
weeks
but i got over it and i mean
the reality is this is what judges face
on reality competition shows especially
something like dragon grace but i mean i
thought for season one
of a show i thought we did a really good
job and i'm really excited
uh hopefully to dive back in for season
two so
the top three was truly incredible we
had
scarlet bobo rita baga and priyanka and
honestly
it was anyone's game i'm so happy that
pre
won she is just fabulous why do you
think priyanka was
the perfect winner of season one in your
eyes
i mean she just the whole season there's
there's just something about her she has
that i'm
that star quality i think like she
really is um
just a lovable character i thought she
brought us some really great drag she
brought
us some really really funny moments she
kind of turned out to be the narrator of
the whole season
like she she was there the whole time
like she was kind of narrating
everything
um she got us some incredible lip syncs
and i really appreciated about her is
that she never gave up she never got
down on herself
you are hitting the road on canada's
drag race
live at the drive-in you're hitting up
four different cities
calgary montreal toronto and ottawa how
does it feel to be going
back on the road and doing what brooklyn
does
i'm so excited honestly it's just gonna
be
it's gonna be really really nice to to
just be out there and especially just to
spend time with the girls i haven't seen
most of them or any of them since the
show
wrapped um so it's gonna be nice to
connect with them on a less stressful
level when i can actually like talk to
them and we can hang out it's gonna be
really cool and i'm just excited for
them i know they are all so excited
just to be able to perform and seeing
your fans again like look you have
fans that sometimes we've done events
together and these
fans follow you wherever you go
um which is no which is really a
beautiful thing and i'm sure for you
too being able to be back on the road
and see those faces who support you
quite literally every single day i'm so
excited to
to get a connect with some of the people
who have
supported me for the last year and a bit
it's crazy
and i really have do have amazing
amazing fans called my little army of
lesbians because they're mostly lesbians
i like the lesbian whisperer apparently
yeah so i'm really excited to see people
and um
through car windows i guess so i'm not
gonna actually physically get to see
people
like touch them and hug them which i
really miss doing but it's gonna be nice
to still like
this even thank you for chatting brooke
all right love you
love you too
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos